ciao a tutti e sono venuto qua a parlare
di un progetto che si chiama rock i
mille che è successo quest'estate il 26
luglio del 2015 mille persone si sono
trovate tutti insieme e
contemporaneamente a suonare un pezzo
dei foo fighters che si chiama si chiama
loro to fly
l'obiettivo era quello di girare un
video all'interno del quale avremo poi
chiesto tutti insieme ai foo fighters
che una band americana di venire a
suonare nella piccola città di cesena
una cosa che era praticamente
impossibile riuscire a realizzare
abbiamo pubblicato online il video
questo è stato immediatamente successo
della madonna tant'è che dave grohl il
insomma il leader dei foo fighters
registra il giorno dopo un video in cui
dice cesena arriviamo grazie è stato
bellissimo che è bellissimo ha detto il
video oggi ha fatto più di 25 milioni di
visualizzazioni
sono tantissime per uno youtuber è
praticamente un sogno riuscire a
realizzare qualcosa di virale io non
sono un 1 youtuber però mi sono
cominciati poco iniziato a fare un po di
domande su che cosa è la viralità ok
quali sono i video virali quindi è
cominciato andare online mi sono accorto
che generalmente i video virali sono di
queste categorie prima categoria epic
fail
paperissima per intenderci seconda
categoria
gattini e cagnolini e bambini
potentissimi
terza categoria programmi televisivi pa
lancio robe del genere quarta categoria
personaggi famosi che fanno robe strane
ultima categoria progetti pianificati
riuscire a pianificare un progetto e
renderlo virale alla cosa estremamente
difficile perché generalmente non c'è
una grande componente di casualità tipo
io faccio un intervista mia nonna con
internet arrivano i marziani con la
videocamera arrivano i marziani dietro
gli obesi marziani che arrivano lo mette
online diventa virale la pianificazione
è un'altra cosa
i big air one
ok questo qui è
l'inizio del progetto rock i mille cioè
da dove è nata l'idea nel 2003 un
capolavoro della cinematografia moderna
che esco love rock ha un contenuto extra
in cui jack black dice che se uno vuole
avere un sogno deve essere in grado di
inginocchiarsi e pregare e funziona
molto di più se dietro ci sono mille
persone che urlano ora questo numero
1000 mi è rimasto in testa per 11 anni
in maniera in forme fino a quando un bel
giorno una sinapsi andando per i cavoli
suoi ha incontrato qualche cos'altro che
la collega the foo fighters scritto
mille foo fighters ok facciamo suonare a
mille persone un prezzo dei foo fighters
facciamo il più grande tributo della
storia della musica si poteva
pianificare questo probabilmente ne ho
c'è le idee non vengono pianificando le
le idee vengono a tutti per tutti noi
abbiamo fondamentalmente qualche sinapsi
che va per i cavoli suoi all'interno del
proprio cervello
quindi una volta messo in piedi questa
idea abbia messo in piedi il team team
tante persone con background differenti
caratteri differenti tutti molto diversi
uomini donne di ogni categoria di ogni
estrazione
questo è stato il nostro team
fondamentale ha funzionato perché ha
funzionato tutti noi avevamo un ruolo
estremamente ben definito nessuno di noi
si è mai permesso di entrare e sparare
entrare nell'ambito di qualchedun altro
andare insegnare come dovevano fare il
loro mestiere e questo ha funzionato
tantissimo perché anche se io lì in
mezzo facevo un po il capoccia
ho sempre rispettato e stimato il lavoro
di tutti ho dato stima e rispetto per
ottenere stime rispetto quindi per un
anno abbiamo lavorato in maniera molto
armonica a questa cosa è questo un
criterio per il successo non lo so
probabilmente no perché ne abbiamo avuto
un gruppo orizzontale però nella storia
ci sono tantissimi casi di leader
dispotici che portavano avanti alla loro
visione sopra gli altri non so steve
jobs bill shankly anche walt disney
dicevano che era un certo e caratterino
l'armonia e un altro criterio per
arrivare alla viralità no la lazio del
ho scoperto che praticamente
si picchiavano negli spogliatoi e
continue risse poi dopo ha vinto il
campionato quindi armonia neanche quella
gli stessi beatles alla fine della loro
carriera
ha partorito il white album ma non si
sopportavano più non si parlavano più
eppure yesterday ho letti di è saltato
fuori da da quel periodo quindi di nuovo
l'armonia
non è stato un criterio fondamentale per
noi ha funzionato ma non necessariamente
funziona sempre quindi che cosa abbiamo
fatto all'interno di rocchi mila il
progetto era diviso in quattro fasi
tutte piuttosto difficili la prima era
un crowdfunding di 40mila euro in italia
molto difficile la seconda era trovare
mille musicisti la terza era a farli
suonare tutti insieme contemporaneamente
e possibilmente produrre della musica e
non del casinò la quarta era riuscire ad
ottenere i foo fighters a cesena devo
dire che tutti questi quattro miracoli
se ne sono verificati tutti e quattro
perché tra due settimane i foo fighters
suoneranno al carisport
bene
ok
abbiamo lavorato a questo progetto
tenendo
tutti dell'età delle tecniche che
vengono spiegate anche in dissemina reti
di comunicazione da 300 euro cioè il
social media lo studio del target i
video e le tecniche di comunicazione il
crowd funding il car sharing tutte
queste cose qua che non sono di nuovo un
criterio per diventare virali sono cose
che bene o male qualsiasi social media
manager o chiunque organizzi eventi più
o meno riesce a mettere in pratica
quindi questo non è stato non ha reso
possibile la viralità che cosa che ha
reso piral e rocky mille probabilmente
questi tre aspetti verità catarsi e seri
di vita allora la verità sta nel fatto
che tutti noi eravamo estremamente
appassionati abbiamo coinvolto persone
che amano la musica amano il rock
alcuni di loro mani i foo fighters non
necessariamente quindi la passione e
l'energia che saltava fuori da questo
video da questa giornata era autentica
era reale ed è stata percepita
un altro aspetto molto importante la
cosiddetta catarsi che cosa la catarsi
immaginate di
trattenere la pipì per una settimana
quando andate in bagno una liberazione
incredibile quella è la catarsi
quindi
tutti questi mille musicisti che sono
venuti a suonare provate a immaginare
persone che magari ci provano da una
vita
cercano di avere successo con la musica
sono costretti ad andare a suonare nei
pub gratis per 50 euro ci provano ma non
riescono ad emergere portaci con una
cosa in cui si divertono la faccia e
sono i protagonisti di un evento che fa
a 25 milioni di spettatori
un successo planetario quindi noi siamo
riusciti a tirare fuori un po di
frustrazione e l'abbiamo trasformato in
un grande successo quest'estate una
catarsi per tutti questi musicisti che
legittimamente sono impazziti di gioia e
quindi questa gioia è stata trasferita
anche al di fuori attraverso il video
che abbiamo messo su youtube e che hanno
percepito tutte le persone che hanno
visto questo video e da qui la
serendipità c'è un insieme un innescarsi
di fenomeni di eventi non attesi che
portano a un successo della madonna
quindi quello che noi abbiamo dato è una
sorta di
cellula staminale di felicità perché la
chiamo staminale perché era legata un
motivo futile non era collegata a
intenti politici ha un interesse di tipo
sociale ha un interesse di tipo
promozionale
tutti hanno beccato questa energia e
l'hanno utilizzata nel modo che
desideravano gli abbia dato un po di
energia che ciascuno ha messo
all'interno dei propri sogni e secondo
me questo è stato uno dei motivi
principali del successo di di questo
video serendipità appunto qualcosa che è
difficile da prevedere
e qua entriamo in un in un campo un po
un po scivoloso cioè che cosa è successo
c'è perché è successo in ora il karma il
destino allineamento astrale dio o il
culo non lo so tutti lo possono vedere
in modi diversi però fatto sta che sta
cosa si è autenticamente verificata ed
era difficilissimo da prevedere perché
tutti noi siamo bravissimi a collegare i
puntini una volta che le cose sono
successe a posteriori ma prima
impossibile saperlo noi siamo vittima di
un meccanismo psicologico che gli
psicologi chiamano
euristica della disponibilità cioè noi
sulla base delle pochissime esperienze
che abbiamo nella nostra vita crediamo
di riuscire a interpretare il futuro ma
non è così
non è così e purtroppo non è così o per
fortuna non è così neanche nei fenomeni
virali perché la realtà è che non
esistono regole
mi dispiace deludervi qualche minuto
qualche di avere il segreto della verità
non esistono regole se ci fossero delle
regole che funzionano
tutti riusciremo tutti riusciremo a
pianificare la viralità ma in realtà le
regole non non ci sono si deve innescare
quel meccanismo di serendipità che
permette un progetto di esplodere e
questo si ottiene probabilmente cercando
provando tantissime volte e questo lo
trovo anche abbastanza confortante
perché mette in primo piano non tanto il
talento che tutti quanti crediamo di
avere magari non è poi così vero
mentre in realtà la cosa più importante
non è il talento ma è la perseveranza e
quindi a me piace molto questa idea che
se in realtà provandoci più volte a un
certo punto qualche cosa può scattare si
può permettere davvero di avere il
nostro di aver successo perché questo è
collegato non tanto delle regole ma alla
nostra unicità di persone quindi tutti
noi possiamo riuscire a creare qualche
cosa di straordinario valorizzando
quello che siamo sul serio grazie
bene
e adesso
prima di andarmene voglio fare questo
esperimento
abbiamo fatto con con un po di amici
cetoli qua che mi ha dato una mano si è
fatto un gran mazzo
abbiamo fatto questa app per gioco è
uscita l'abbiamo finita due giorni fa
l'abbia messa nello store agli amici di
di google sono un po più veloci degli
amici di iphone
quindi chi sa a chi android chiedo di
andare avanti e far partire questa
questa app e prego quelli che hanno
android di alzarsi in piedi
ok allora quest'app è molto stupida però
probabilmente molto divertente
il mio obiettivo è quello di far suonare
una di creare una sorta di mini rok i
mille all'interno di questa sala
ed è pensata per persone che in realtà
non sanno suonare
quindi l'obiettivo è questo
seguitemi
allora fate partire la app selezionate
lo strumento che volete suonare che ne
so questi di qua suonano la chitarra
quelli al centro suona la chitarra in
alto quelli al centro sono la chitarra
in basso quelli a sinistra sono la
batteria
una volta che wrap parte agitando il
telefono il telefono suona quindi i
chitarristi devono fare così le batterie
si devono fare presente
ok
alzate a palla il volume dei telefonini
perché questo chi è esattamente il
contrario di quello che succede di
solito e vediamo quello che succede ora
la cosa importante è riuscire a partire
tutti sincronizzati era un problema che
avevamo a rocky e mille ce l'avremmo
anche questa sera quindi quando tutti
sono pronti e hanno la schermata con
scritto tap to start altino braccia
tutti siete pronti tap to start
ok allora al mio tre
proviamo a cliccare tanto start e
diamoci dentro a rockeggiare ok
1237 agitare
i batteristi devono fare così perché
sennò non suonano
ok lo so la cosa più stupida del mondo
grazie